we begin this half hour with news of yet
another mass shooting this time in
norway police in oslo the capitol say at
least two people were killed when a
gunman known to police opened fire
outside a bar that is popular among the
city's lgbtq plus community nearly two
dozen people were injured the attack
happened just ahead of a gay pride
parade ian lee is in our london bureau
with the very latest ian good morning
good morning dana in recent hours
norwegian police have declared the
attack an act of terrorism one
eyewitness described a man arriving
outside the bar around one in the
morning he was holding a bag then pulled
out a gun and started shooting bullets
hit multiple people as well as nearby
businesses shattering glass windows and
sending debris flying through the air
another witness described how the gunman
took careful aim before shooting his
victims he then opened fire at two other
nearby locations before police
eventually arrived and arrested him
authorities are describing the suspect
as a 42-year-old norwegian citizen of
iranian descent he's now being charged
with murder and acts of terrorism police
recovered a gun and an automatic weapon
at the scene as of now officials don't
believe anyone else was involved but
today was supposed to be oslo's pride
parade authorities don't yet know if the
shooting is connected but there is an
increased security presence in the city
the parade and other pride festivities
have now been canceled following advice
from the police jeff
all right ian lee with the latest on
this shooting in norway ian thank you
very much